the problem with the way the government
behaved suppressing even true speech
even just regular scientific debate it
undermined the TR the public trust in
these institutions like the CDC like the
US surgeon general's office and as a
result the government lost the ability
to effectively counter misinformation
like that with more speech and I think
that's that's my I mean I think that's
the right thing if the if the government
is telling their the the honest truth as
best they know how and they build up
trust with the public as a result of it
there's not going to be a big problem
with misinformation PE people will say
wrong things all the time but that's not
that's not the problem the problem is
the inability to counter it with
trustworthy sources free speech allows
that the kind of suppression of speech
we had basically undermines the capacity
to deal with it uh Kate any comment from
you on the question I just want to point
out that you just said that the
government should build an institution
that can measure these types of things
and that is literally like kind of one
of the things that the CDC is in charge
of doing and so the fact that this is
something that kind of that the fact
that this was something that was
happening and that the government was
putting this forward and also that one
of the recommendations in the giant
record that you make mention of in the
in the Missouri V Biden case was that a
lot of these requests were essentially
that they that Twitter didn't answer
them by T or Twitter or Facebook or
whatever didn't answer them by taking
down speech often they would put counter
speech up they would put they would
allow like something like the chips and
vaccines type of thing to go up and then
they would put like they would put a lab
on it that said something effectively
like this has been disputed by so and so
and we're not sure if this is accurate
information and that was also called
censorship and so that is something that
I I think that like you just that what
you just said is something that you've
said the opposite for like and that
people who have supported and said that
these claims are censorship is not I
mean this can't all be censorship
everything that is like happening can't
all be censorship and it can't be having
speech and counter speech by the
government can't both be SP K they they
banned vaccine injured groups from
talking to each other at the request of
the government the the um the who's they
they being the Biden Administration
forced the Facebook to do that forc
Facebook absolutely in the in the in the
in the records of the uh Missouri versus
Biden case uh not not only that like I'd
say like the the way that they in the
ham-handed way they forced the social
media companies to tag Mis like false
information misinformation actually I
think spread further distrust right so
they put go see what the CDC is saying
on absolutely true things so essentially
saying look this what what this regular
Joe is saying on online is wrong even if
it was it's just a link to a
peer-reviewed paper and they put it on
uh on these on these like you know
vaccines are are are are microchipped I
I think it was an ABS the the way that
the government regulated speech online
censored speech online absolutely fueled
the distrust of a significant ific
fraction of the public about the
vaccines it was an
absolute disaster for public health
communication but you just said the
counter speech was the way to solve the
problem of allowing First Amendment
protected speech that was wrong to stay
up I I didn't say that this was counter
speech I'm saying that what they did was
censoring I I'm saying that what they
that they if they wanted to build what
was censoring the labels that you say or
counter speech are now also censorship
no that what was what was no I didn't
say that you said that what I said was
that the bid administration's demand to
put the labels on was censorship it was
defamation of of people's even when they
were saying correct things whether true
or false those labels went up uh the the
the Biden administration's demands to
put the counter speech isn't I get to I
get to be there as the government right
in front of you every time you say
something that's not counter speech
counter speech is uh that you have a CDC
that says we've done a scientific study
here's the here's the thing and they buy
they buy uh advertising on the platform
they have public PSAs they there other
mechanisms other than intruding on how
the social media companies present and
regulate the speech that they have what
what they did was absolutely censorship
they prevented vaccine injured people
from talking to each other they forced
Facebook to take down speech of vaccine
injured people what do you think was
going to happen to them they're not
going to start trusting the government
on
this K you want yeah all right well next
question